[Music]
in career change news whoa somebody
gonna change the career I don't know I
don't want a career submitted by JK come
to Norway please okay tomorrow yeah
colder Norway Halsey Daniel day-lewis is
quitting acting what come a dress maker
what does all kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] of that you got one morning
shoes your shoe maker you're not given a
frickin cobbler ah do the logician maker
yeah you love making shoes like my
traditional leather shoes well I was
thinking like high-heeled shoes I don't
know if in Holland I thought they're
like mention its treasure but like but
like now he's going into dresses like
he's gonna be like little bit down I
feel like it's before a movie here you
know I'm saying cuz he's super method
quitting acting like one more role in
that city they've done why I'm not as
passionate do them good at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] why does he have to announce it
yeah that's exactly why Michael Jordan
going to some baseball no I don't even
got why he is man Michael Jordan maybe
he's not even announcing it it's maybe
like his agency he's like hey I'm done
like why what are you gonna do I'm gonna
make dresses and then I think it just
kind of typing good at it he's one of
the best actor that ever lived
so this is Daniel day-lewis for those of
you guys who don't know it's a big fan
of him yeah part loves him with
billboards is he like into Michael
Jordan well maybe it's like in Being
John Malkovich when they entered his
brain and took over his body and yet is
in Soul and then John Malkovich
announced he's gonna be a puppeteer
instead of an actor and it was like you
know while you're doing that and it
turns out it was someone else in his
brain that's all oh it's crane that's
such AI you guys wants a movie super
dope mm-hmm yes Jose was a ninja turtle
River
it's a mold oh yes great training yes
yeah so right now he's working on what's
going to be his last film as an actor
and so their reports are calling it
phantom thread but the distributor is
saying that is still entitled
know what kind of dresses is evening it
means it's gonna feel lightweight and
you can't even tell us on you factor
what's her about the moon oh hang on
oh I was right and it there which is
okay because I feel really stupid for a
second I saw your face fully transition
is already he's doing urban well I'm
slightly sunburst hmm and some thread
currently untitled like his dress and
sound like a JV a that's the movie
you're going to be working on and so
what they're saying this in what is it
about though the movie is about an
uncompromising dressmaker commissioned
by royalty and high society who said
that Jim I didn't know he was getting
into his role so much an actor and I was
going love that yeah so before so he was
learning to play a role where he had to
be a shoemaker and took five years off
your semi-retired back in the 90s to
become a shoemaker he even lived in
Italy for that but now he's saying he's
going to fully retire from acting and
recently the last three years he's been
uh chill in the fashion game he's been
announcing that he loves
he's been loving creating dresses akia
work is also a method actor when he was
preparing for the role in Iron Man he
stayed in a Russian prison but how long
because he wanted to be a crook I want
to stay here
I love the caviar of this prison he was
a resident he was a Russian prisoner or
a Russian criminal so he stayed he went
to Russia and he stayed in a prison for
like a month or two I wouldn't get
butt-fucked for method acting not afraid
to say I don't know if that's the
Russian cohabit is American come there
is a story I forget we love rewriting
there was no Dennis Hoffman right was
the og actor there was a younger actor
who had some part in the movie and the
part in the movie was like the guy was
homeless or some [ __ ] like that so this
is this younger actor so I camped out I
added in a dumpster for like two weeks
to like you know really get into the
character and being super meta with it
he showed up on set he was like you know
this is what I did blah blah and this
happens like why don't you just act why
don't you try acting first innocent
Dustin Dustin Dustin Hoffman oh yeah
that was that's what kind of dresses are
we going to be making couture
Wow Wow is that what that is like the
high fashion high so he's going to be
making the one where the ladies look
like a lab or like a [ __ ] pirate ship
or something like not like that like a
little illuminated come inside fashion
is like these like [ __ ] no [ __ ]
don't wear those because they're runway
show dollars and dresses issued yeah cuz
I'm like dude this lady look like she's
from future and [ __ ] this look like
something like Kanye gets jealous when
these ladies wear this curse of like
what the [ __ ] do I be loving these girls
who are in my [ __ ] seat to toss this
[ __ ] for no reason yeah Thank You
fashion chain say I support that wave
heal your chick does it it's like ah
this is stupid why would you watch you
hide those things god damn it I'm the
opposite I want my girlfriend to be a
[ __ ] not me not a [ __ ] I want her to
look like like that like the the runway
you want her to look but making walking
around public yep if you had her nipples
like a seafood thing where nips on
I wouldn't mind I want Jessica to just
wear pasties and walk around a street
with me because I feel covered oh that's
so Cullen because she's classy think
about why parents oh we already was like
this but first of all this was a long
time ago
and no and I was upset at white leggings
because I was like hey because white
leggings are super hot they're like guy
I magnets yes they are you cannot like
oh shut up you don't have sex in my
mother must to a flame
and she had bottom white leggings early
in the relationship and I was like yo
it's so hot okay like before you wear
him out can you let me see let me see
you in them first that was manipulation
that she messed up and then I found out
she had wanted to kick with her homies
and I was like oh your homeboys got to
see you cakes and the beautiful white
leggings before me I was pissed about
that I don't know if you want to
your eyes - best to be [ __ ] by the
leggings first I don't think I don't
think anybody is just okay with their
significant other guy order yeah he's
pretty ugly
you're pretty literal I'm liberal but I
don't want your nipple I don't want you
to be wearing a funny hat read or write
what I do and she's on my arm and what
and without then I I don't think I
wouldn't rip I don't think so
but if she was in in Canada like she's
right now currently and just out at the
club with the nips out I probably be
like a mini chill out and it depends how
I met you so if you are already a
stripper like let's say I dated Rihanna
she's already butt naked all the time
then it's cool you know from your voice
it depends on Jaime if I met you're not
close up all the time also know and be
butt naked and it's different that's
exactly much I'm just about met them
yeah if she was a stripper I'll be like
cover up let me see you something doing
something different like it's very one
of those [ __ ] Little House on the
Prairie dresses like a [ __ ] from a
Western like please like cover that [ __ ]
up I always see you in just a bikini
right I want you to look like a [ __ ]
Irish housewife dad how [ __ ] cold box
all over your face come on change it up
look like you're one of the nuns or
something freedom and people they have
to go to the coal mine yeah Daniel
day-lewis oh yeah it's actually um it's
making a lot of headlines because he is
the only actor to ever get three Oscars
for Best Actor oh he's like been there
done that I'm too [ __ ] good for the
[ __ ] or the movies you got Best Actor
you got Best Actor for my left foot in
1989 okay no no no plastic ah Thank You
York there will be blood in 2007 yeah
and Lincoln yeah oh we should probably
get on that either yeah from one
accomplishment to another though I
understand what it's like
and one thing and then you want to just
move on right right
the things that I kill in like people
might not like really care about but
then like for me it's like oh yeah I did
this [ __ ] easy like I [ __ ] killed it
give me an example sugarcane juice
farmer he never did it idea though
that's that's one thing yeah because I'm
still trying to kill it like like online
so then after that is like yeah I'm
going to [ __ ] grow some sugarcane
right but that's like an 80 year old
sport mm-hmm right now I'm doing a young
man thing I have plans
okay well like it's like one thing is
like hey do did you know how to annoy
people on the internet really well yeah
all right killed it move killed it
[ __ ] move on to the next because
you're into that mm-hmm what's the next
thing I'm trying to do martial art not
for the reason you guys think I'm not
trying to beat people up can I get beat
up really well mmm
can I do that good all right you okay so
I'm I'm a hacker right like you're
trying to do you're trying to like
efficiently do things and win and things
that other people aren't winning it so
go against the grain I'm a rebel
right everyone tries to play sports to
win I play to lose em you want to see
see if you can lose more harder than
other losers yep who can out lose all
the losers who can get beat more than I
can and still [ __ ] stand up that's a
[ __ ] warrior think I'm gonna use
a competition it's because I lose I lose
a lot of [ __ ] all right we'll see we'll
see yeah a lot of [ __ ] to those things
on that guy and you move on to the neck
like I think I don't like being cut it
big so I want to be dope Isha's I like
but it's never that way never that way
man like all I'm good at my [ __ ]
falling over breaking my ankle this [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] expertise hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you I other than that you know it's
like more videos up there bro
[Music]